now welcome to this video playing G
brave RGB ray let's see from the US okay
e 6 g 6 ok King Simeon or groom felt
nice taking a star okay so recently I
played this H for the edge for line
again against this opening and that
didn't turn out so well I didn't turn
out so badly didn't turn out so well
write it was quite quite nice nothing
leading two to interesting positions
okay so if I go eat high f yeah let's go
in five now that you cannot play here
shouldn't be too bad so is there some
way to to play for direct attack here
age 50 is this totally crazy probably it
is hmm
hmm come on if it's not working listen
it's just a blitz game okay he's not
spending any time just going 45 ok c 5
is not illogical but still still rather
quick okay so let's let's take on g6
hmm so how to how to play this I mean I
really think it should be there is some
danger for black holes the H file is
open Queen d3 and tending Queen g6
sounds 11 idea okay I can't play okay if
I spent much more time won't help the
Queen G success is very simple but it is
a threat which she completely ignores
wow isn't this working question this
winning now I don't know
Queen h7 mate and that's it I don't see
a defense yeah I thought maybe Bishop f5
was correct
very complicated of course maybe maybe
it's not it's not great for white I mean
the h5 was open but he's got enormous
counterplay in the center so it's
possible that all this was was good for
black but ok after this blunder I think
I'm just meeting I don't see I don't see
how he prevents the mate
yeah this reading a move Queen their son
it's no way to do a cover the square
yes let's letting the clock run down the
Sun is not new so we had a relatively
new account probably all right so let's
just wait and while we added I can try
to do some analysis and I thought Bishop
f5 here I cannot move the pieces of
course the game is still going he's
letting the clock run down um on Bishop
f5 I thought could night before and then
trying to after seat XD trying to get to
the edge from the c6 is a possible with
that
yeah I don't know probably blackest is
good though it looks like my centers
shaky and I don't have a very powerful
continuation gap Bishop f5 was probably
probably right here I can do some
computer aided analysis after he finally
has resigned or if the clock whatever is
down to down to zero just the typical
childish behavior that people sometimes
have here so Bishop f5 I really think
you should do that I'm not sure that
other moves do the job or they are
really passive like e6 or something this
looks like a passive move Bishop f5 I
think seems good okay but um I thought
nitey forward maybe maybe um I also
should consider Queen III yeah but it's
not threatening much e six maybe maybe
this is frightening new six but 94 was
my plan I would have I would have played
this rather rather quickly and then she
takes the forum yeah probably Black is
fine how long is it three seconds all
right black for effects on time so he
let me wait like four minutes and let's
just now check this a bit probably well
the computer says why this very good
here okay but not with 94 it wants to go
Queenie too we had the idea being he's
67 this is probably not good no it's not
good after this the combi doesn't see a
convincing move it wants to go here and
then here yeah but couldn't be six yeah
probably i would have I would have been
in big trouble objectively it seems that
Queenie two is good but I think I
I wouldn't have played it I planned an
idea flaw yeah this is a good good
threat now let's see here and then this
is even strong yeah tending to take and
then Queen h5 this is very important and
this is a big threat let's say here here
cannot do add of course check at the end
Black is exploding here so it was
dangerous and probably not bad but I
think I probably would have gone
Australia with 94 and after that yeah
there's no real really good attacking
continuation one point is that this is
an immediate threat so I cannot let's
say play here because of 95 alright
thanks for watching